[Music]
couples retreat this is when you just
know it's a slow movie week so couples
retreat ultimately stars Vince Vaughn
company and is directed by Peter
Billingsley and for those of you who
don't recognize that name he's better
known as Ralphie from A Christmas Story
yeah Ralphie directed couples retreat
but unlike Christmas Story you won't be
watching couples retreat at any holiday
gatherings Valentine's Day dinners or
even a boring Tuesday night with nothing
else to do Ralphie how could you the
plot goes Jason Bateman and Kristen Bell
are considering getting a divorce
and so have decided to go to a place
called Eden a place of paradise and
couples skill-building and they found a
great group rate so now they can bring
their friends so their friends
relationships can get dragged through
the mud along with theirs hey what are
friends for
however this place is pretty miraculous
I would probably jump into a [ __ ]
relationship myself just so I can get
shipped off to a place like this for a
week I'm awesome we're talking free
gourmet food sightseeing and tropical
paradise I mean can't a miserable and
rocky relationship be more fun but after
they arrived the movie unfolds exactly
how you think it's going to like exactly
honestly you can just watch the trailer
and know exactly how this movie's gonna
go aside from the cliche plot the movie
had a couple of laughs but also had more
drop off punchlines you know what I'm
talking about like it looks like there's
a scene where a big jokes building so
it's like little jokes little jokes
little joke ends that's it
teams over next scene the joke just
drops off I mean it feels like the Hiro
and Ando campaign post season one it
just feel useless it almost feels like
the movie was gonna be rated R and then
they cut it back to pg-13 after they
film the movie so the big punchlines in
these scenes are just gone
and as for the characters you don't care
about them like at all you don't care if
the relationships work out maybe Vince
Vaughn and Faison love these are the
only two you might care about the rest
know havens a tool Favreau's a douche
you don't care I mean I like the actors
but the movie did them no justice I have
seen more justice in the OJ trial and
that's okay trial 95 not do seven it's
kind of funny how you have to
distinguish nowadays what a dumbass so
now because I'm a nice guy I will break
down the cliche plot right here and save
you money which some might consider a
spoiler but as I said before you already
know exactly how this plots gonna break
down on account that you saw the trailer
so not really a spoiler and it goes wow
this place is awesome you have to do
couples therapy huh couples therapy
don't want to but you have to okay how
bad can it be
we're fine yeah we are hahaha I'm tired
of controlling me huh
Wow how can I not seen this inevitable
plot twist of a problem I hate you I
hate you I can't live without you you're
my heir
Wow we came for the fun stuff but ended
up learning a lesson that drew us closer
together in the end
I love being cliche don't you in a
nutshell that's what you're in for
God willing they all meet up together in
the straight-to-dvd sequel couples
retreat to that prenup and what's up
with the Guitar Hero segment did we wake
up in a world where through the fire and
flames on expert mode is not the most
impressive feat in the history of ever I
don't care if it's a couple Guitar Hero
generations passed through the fire and
flames always through the firearm flames
Dragonforce sorry Ralphie for this you
getting no Red Rider BB gun this here
[Music]